when you think back uh
and you think of
like your time with d12
um
by the way devil's night yeah
[ __ ] incredible project uh
i think uh i think of like
vmas i think like mtv show i just i when
i think of mtv i think of like the
purple hills video yeah
yeah
what was your craziest recording session
during the d12 days when you guys were
working on those projects
uh
craziest sessions oh man those were like
[ __ ] strippers was it oh
it was a lot of work man it's a lot of
work i think we have fun after the
studio but
[ __ ] you know being in the studio within
man sometimes you could you might be in
a booth for five six hours wow doing one
verse over
he was such a perfectionist yeah he was
on your ass so like you had to he had to
make sure hey look i'm on this
[ __ ] with y'all y'all gotta make
sure he gets sick man
i mean one time he got so sick with it
man
i went home he he wanted me to do some
ad-libs over
and uh
i guess he could wait for me so i came
back the next day he had did him for me
did they stay on there he he sounded
just like me my voice and i was like bro
you are sick
you are sick man
that's crazy yeah it was his uh his
writing process like we like nowadays
a lot of the newer artists they punch in
so they just do line by line and they
don't really write anything down yeah
which i think there's like positives and
negatives to that yeah um
positives you probably get a lot more
done okay i think negatively like you
maybe
each line maybe don't count the way it
should yeah because you're coming up
around the spot but like what was was m
always out of the notepad
yeah always off the notepad yeah he feel
like if he if he ain't um
for like
he feels like he's the top i was
opposite of me
i don't write raps
unless i'm going to the studio
it has to be a beat someone should play
just i don't have you don't have like
notepads and [ __ ] like if you asked me
to spit at 16 right now i couldn't
yeah because you don't have the beat
playing no i know i don't even know
nothing i don't even know my old [ __ ]
that's cool you don't remember any of
your old lyrics no i have to ask the
other group members on stage right
before the court is coming soon
really yeah yeah yeah all the time yeah
so
yeah man
but him
he feels like
he's wasting the engineer's time
if
he don't have anything prepared
and it's his studio and he's paying the
engineer yeah
yeah but he feel like you know so he's
just got the notepad ready to go yeah
you know and i i remember one
some advice that he gave me that that i
never followed but i should have
followed this [ __ ]
he said man sometimes just go over the
verses over and over again like when you
take it home
and you sit and ask yourself
did i say the dopest line right here
could i could i have said something
better right here
and if you think you could have you know
what i'm saying changing
you know what i'm saying or
but i never listened
[Laughter]
i'm like [ __ ] that i'm going back to the
hotel but it's [ __ ] for 10 hours